همم في كل المقترحات الدوليه دائما ما
كانت تصدم بعقبات لحل الشان الليبي او لحل
هذه الازمه الليبيه وين المشكله في
المجتمع الدولي ولا في الداخل الليبي
بعض الدول تنظر لمصالحها الشخصيه في هذه
المساله ولا تنظر لصالح العامه لكن زي ما
همم تفضل في البدايه وقلت لحضرتك ان الوضع
هذا عندها اثاره جوار وعلى المحيط
الاقليمي والدولي على سبيل المثال الان
قضيه السلاح والتجاره في السلاح والهجره
غير شرعيه وتجاره المخدرات وتجاره
الترامادول وكل انواع هدايا اللي حالته
وهل الهجره اللي لان اوروبا كلها
حتى التنظيمات اللي موجوده جنوب الصحراء
هي معروفه حضرتك تعرفيها تنظيمات القاعده
وتنظيمات الاسلاميه اداء البطاقه كلها
الان موجوده في منطقه الجنوب فنحن امام
مواقع سيء للنذيب يا مش دوله يعني موقعها
ليبيا تقع على جنوب ابيض البحر الابيض
المتوسط في 2000 كيلو متر في مواجهه
مباشره مع اليونان مع ايطاليا مع فرنسا
همم اقصد يعني من حيث الموقع اللي همم
الجغرافي
لان هذه الدول
ومن خلف دول كثيره يعني خاصه المجموعات
الارهابيه سيكون لها اثر سيئه جدا على
المحيط في مكان على مصر على تونس على حتى
الخليج العربي على المغرب العربي
يزداد يتطور في هذه المنطقه
على انه هذه الازمه ازمه الجماعات المسلحه
قد طال الدول الجوار قد طال الدول
الاوروبيه ايضا ولكن ما بدات بذكر حضرتك
ما يتوافق ما يراها المواطن اللي بالعادي
اللي اصبح يقول ان اللعبه التي يمارسها
السياسيون همم الليبيون همم هي التي تعرقل
المسار لانه في نهايه الامر هم متنفعون هم
لهم المصلحه في ذلك لانهم يعرفون انه لو
تخلوا عن هذه اللعبه سيتم لفظهم من كل
الشعب الليبي همم
ما رايك في هذا الكلام يعني المسؤوليه
يتحملها السياسيون اكثر حتى من الجهات
الدوليه او الخارجيه
حتى نفترض يعني همم
اذا كان ارادوا انهم ينتخبوا حكومه جديده
من خلال مجلس النواب وبالتنسيق حتى مع
مجلس الدوله ولا اي جسم كان كان لن يحترف
بها دوليا
العامل الدولي هو اساس الموضوع الليبي
نتيجه
تحت الفصل السابع في عام 2011 واصبح
سيادتها الوطنيه
توحيد همم القوات المسلحه
جيشنا الوطني
احنا الحمد لله الدوله ما دخلناش في اي
صراع مع احد يعني طول الزمن احنا مسالمين
وشعب مسالم نحاول نبني انفسنا بانفسنا
ولهذا لا بصراحه بقدر صح الليبيين يتحملوا
جزء كبير من هذه المسؤوليه كاسياسين
وانعكس هذا الامر بشكل سيء على اهلنا وعلى
مواطنين او على معشتهم الان يعيشوا فيها
اليوم المواطن الذي استاذه منتهى واحد في
قوت يومها المواطنين مش لاقي خدمه صحيه
مناسبه مش لاقي تعليم مناسب مش لاقي مرافق
مناسبه والامر اصبح يتطور في مناطق الجنوب
اللي ينتج فيها النفط وينتج فيها الخيرات
المواطن مش قادر يحصل على الوقود متاح
التيار الكهربائي باربع بخمسه بست ساعات
في مناطق كثيره من الليل اذن الوضع اصبح
سيء جدا يعني انعكاسه على على اهل الشعب